this is jocko podcast number 254
with echo charles and me jaco willink
good evening echo good evening
and joining us again is dave burke good
evening dave
good evening last
few podcasts 251 with leigh babin 252
253 also with dave burke
we've been making our way through the
book guidelines
for the leader and commander which i
brought my actual sacred
real copy not just the photocopy so dave
could lay eyes on it
and we're approaching the halfway point
we should get to the halfway point today
no promises
because there's this book is dense
there's all kinds of stuff to unpack
this is the root of the book that taught
me
the most about leadership about faith by
colonel david hackworth
hackworth references this book
multiple times in about face so the book
is
guidelines for the leader and commander
by general bruce carr
bruce clark world war one world war ii
korea
distinguished service cross three silver
stars 45 years of service as a leader
and a trainer
in the army plenty lessons to learn and
we're learning them
we are learning them so let's get into
it chapter eight
philosophies and principles of training
in overseas areas
this is a whole section on how do you
train when you're deployed
section one the training task the
missions
the primary mission of all u.s military
forces
is to deter communist aggression and if
deterrence fails to defeat aggression
when and where it occurs so
sometimes i work with companies and they
want to have a mission statement
there's a good example of a mission
statement that's what you're trying to
do
this is what you can make so many
decisions
based on that kind of mission statement
what your job is
why do we exist you ever thought about
that one why do i exist what am i here
for
you ever think about that echo charles
yes you think to yourself
i'm here too i haven't come up with
answer yet
we're working it make some video i don't
know press record apparently
check the mission of the united states
army in oversea
in oversea areas stem logically
from this broad u.s forces mission our
first commission is to ensure the
readiness of u.s army forces to defeat
communist aggression in overseas
theaters
in doing so we contribute most
effectively to the accomplishment of our
deterrence mission
additionally we have the mission to
support u.s contingency operations
in peripheral areas the lebanon
and congo operations are examples
in of such contingencies these missions
require that all
u.s army personnel and units instantly
be ready
to undertake combat operations this
requirement provides the basis for all
overseas
training objectives which are presented
and discussed in the
following paragraph so here's what i
think you find
in organizations that really nice
kind of clean thing gets put out to the
troops
and then the troops start to do their
job and they start to live their lives
and they lose track of this
it can happen to an organization it can
happen to you as a human being
you kind of forget where you're going
you forget what you're trying to do
you forget what the team is here for you
forget what the mission is
can't let that happen gotta think about
that stuff
easy to veer off of course it's so easy
just to
shh just to get off course a little bit
have you ever seen you must have seen
this um gulf war
one go for one i'm almost positive
uh helicopters are holding station
they're
they're holding station and there's a
blue on blue and they end up shooting
a an apc i want to say was it a bradley
i know i know what you're talking about
it's a friendly position
i thought it might even have been marine
lavs maybe i might have been in l.a but
but it's yeah it's a lightly armored
american vehicle yep
and you can hear it it's it's one of the
most
horrific things to listen to but what
happens is
these helicopters are in position and
there's just a little bit of a cross
breeze
just a little bit of a cross breeze and
so they don't really recognize it
because they're just slowly getting
blown
off of their where they're supposed to
be and guess what there's multiple
helicopters they're all getting blown
off so
relative to the other helicopters
they're in position and it's the open
desert
and it's hard to tell where you are in
the open desert there's no real
oftentimes there's no real clean
reference points oh there's the
the mountain with the little peak next
to it or there's the river or
whatever those things don't exist just
big flat open
so these guys drift and the next thing
you know they're calling in hey we see
an armored vehicle
well there should be no armored vehicles
in your area well are you sure yeah
we're sure
you should engage that and not only do
they engage the vehicle
some of the guys get out of the vehicle
they engage the guys to get out it's
it's
absolutely it's a it's it's a night it's
a complete nightmare and here's the
really crazy thing
when once that call goes down and the
pilot
realizes what he did
and he says something like you can hear
in his voice he's going to throw up
he's just absolutely sick to his stomach
and he says uh
you know can we return to base we just
we just we just engaged
our friendly troops and whoever's the
air mission commander is that the right
term
i guess as the air mission commander
says you know negative go back to
station and
hold for you know enemy enemy vehicles
that's where you know you still have
your job
but what an example of a little slow
drift off of course
with catastrophic results
that can happen when we lose sight of
what our mission is
back to the book objectives of training
in order to ensure effective
accomplishment of assigned combat
operational contingency and peacetime
operation missions
the training goal of u.s forces overseas
is to maintain
all units and headquarters of the high
command in a state of combat readiness
this goal is equally applicable to
combat combat support technical
administrative type units
and it is attained through careful
attention to the following
seven specific training objectives
so you know you're in an organization
and we always think of
whatever the whatever the critical mode
the critical piece of that organization
is
whether it's the frontline person
whether it's the front line infantryman
whoever's making the actual you know
hand-to-hand combat who's doing the work
we always focus on them and he's laying
out everybody else combat support
technical administrative type units
everyone's important
and they all have to be trained with
this mission in mind
so here's the objectives one maintain
the proficiency of the individual
soldier
that's number one proficiency of the
individual soldiers number one
number two develop a high
degree of responsibility and
resourcefulness
in the commanders and key personnel both
officers and non-commissioned officers
of
all units
and one thing you know as i continue to
read through this book
you can you can sense there is
there are threads there is there is
remaining dna
of world war one of centralized command
of like obedience and you can feel
you can feel some of that in there and
you can also feel the rejection of that
and so that's why when he says things
like hey it's responsibility and
resourcefulness
right you this is to you know we need
our subordinate units to take ownership
we need our
supported officers to take ownership and
figure out how to do things
that's what that's the number two look
we want our soldiers to be proficient
number two we want our leaders
to be resourceful and to take ownership
number three achieve on a continuing and
progressive basis
the effective integration of new weapons
and equipment new organization and new
techniques at all levels of command
learning is what the marine corps came
out with that manual
how how legit was that yeah
i mean he's basically saying you need to
figure that you need an inventive
adapt you need to figure this out you
need to figure this out and by the way
continuing progressive basis when does
that end
oh that's right it doesn't end
continuing progressive basis doesn't end
next maintain an effective fighting team
of the combined arms and supporting
units
maintain an effective integrated team of
the branches and services
we need to work together and and so so
combined arms what is combined arms
combined arms is the use of multiple
different weapons platforms
all in conjunction to support each other
it's the
sort of the highest form of covered move
right because we got aircraft in the sky
that are covering the tanks as they move
in the tanks are covering for infantry
the infantry are also covering the tanks
actually
artillery covering all people so this is
combined
arms it's all these elements covering
and moving for each other
what'd i miss on that the piece of that
too
you got it right is is the intent there
sooner or later
the enemy's gonna have to respond to
something and when they respond to the
tanks that frees up the infantry they
respond to the aircraft that frees up
the tanks whatever it is
and the beauty of that is that all these
different things you're bringing to bear
i don't care which one is the one that
ends up closing the deal i don't care if
it's the tanks that take the final shot
of the aircraft we don't care
we're gonna work together we're gonna
create a problem for the enemy that they
cannot handle they gotta
pick one and they're gonna lose to the
other and i don't care which one it is
and this bring forth this brings forth
one of my favorite doctrinal terms
of all time which is
it's the equivalent of checkmate
which is we are going to capture the
enemy in the combined
arms dilemma meaning there is no escape
you're either going to get killed by the
infantry by the air
by the artillery by armor we have you
you're in checkmate that is the combined
arms dilemma where we have you
one of my favorite doctrinal terms
that put a smile on my face for the day
also talks about i already said this one
but maintain an effective integrated
team of the branches and services oh yes
army navy marine corps air force all
need to work together
develop a high degree of competence in
combined and joint operations
once again it's it's interesting
teamwork teamwork teamwork all the last
three of these are all about working
together
and and was the last one develop
coordination techniques for the
effective accomplishment
of inter-allied operations so it's
teamwork
it's out of the seven four of them are
about teamwork
we have to learn how to work together
understanding the cycles of training
combat readiness is the joint joining of
well-trained men with properly
maintained equipment in an organization
the first requirement is that the men of
this unit be trained as individuals
and as a team to carry out their combat
jobs with thoroughness and speed
this task surpasses all others
for the commander overseas
that type of clarity once again if
you're a commander on the ground
and you're looking at hey what's my
priority there you go
this task surpasses all all others
for commanders overseas is to make sure
that guys are trained
individuals to work as a team to carry
out their jobs that's the most important
thing
readiness training is therefore the
first priority task of every such
unit commander within the concept of
readiness training each commander will
be required to plan cycles or phases of
training to meet
varying situations and requirements the
most conspicuous of which
is an annual loss of approximately 50
percent of his personnel who will be
replaced by soldiers of varying levels
of
training and service and look the whole
time i'm reading this book and you and i
had a funny conversation when i started
sending you pictures of
texts of like little sections of the
book and you eventually sent me a text
to just just cover the whole
thing and i'm like i will but i you know
i
i there's parts of it where i go you
know what that's not 100
applicable or i'm not really sure how
that ties in and sometimes there are
some
points where we get to a level of detail
what i found so interesting why i wanted
to read
this is there's not too many you know
when you hear when you talk civilian
companies they're thinking oh well you
know in the army you've got these guys
and they're trained and they're selected
and
you know everyone's got this this
baseline of training
well guess what you're also losing 50 of
your people annually they're just
cycling out they're either getting out
and this isn't even talking wartime this
is just like life
people move on so you're constantly
in this struggle to train and maintain
efficiency and every
time you train someone every for every
person you train one of those
one of those people that you trained
leaves one out of every two people that
you train leaves
which is which makes it a hard job
what do you got i'm already coming back
to the very first thing you said which
is
you said the word clarity i think a
couple times now and just hearing
that mission statement of what we do the
amount of clarity
in his first comment here's our mission
we are here to deter an enemy if we
don't we're going to fight them and kill
them
that's our mission and the very next
thing he says is everybody else's role
is to train to be prepared to do that
that actually sounds
really simple but it's really hard to
create a message
that's that clear so by which the
infantryman
and the person who's running
administration who seem like completely
different
have clarity in how what they do
contributes to the overall mission
that is not easy to do and this idea of
communicating
in a simple clear and concise manner
which we talk all the time it's really
hard but from the very beginning
he's like hey this is the mission here
are seven things that we're going to do
to allow that to happen supporting
commanders your job is to make it happen
so he's tying all these things together
and it sounds so simple when i'm hearing
him say but i'm realizing how hard that
actually is in an organization
to get everybody to understand what it
is they do
to contribute if you can make your
administrative folks
feel like they are war fighters you have
a clear mission statement yeah
imagine that i have no idea how many
troops he's talking to it's talking
about overseas
american troops this is millions of yeah
maybe not millions but this is hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of troops
this continual turnover of personnel
precludes commanders from programming a
single
training cycle common to all men as
employed in a basic training center it
requires a programming of a number of
successive cycles which may overlap to
some degree
and at times may operate concurrently
during any 12-month period the commander
will need to place emphasis on the
following cycles of training
so again he's just emphasizing the fact
that you're going to lose people you're
going to lose them all the time
and that's going to make your job hard
here's the things that you need to
focus on advance individual training to
improve the proficiency of minimum
service soldiers
or to provide refresher training for men
of longer service
so you've got to just train individuals
basic unit training to improve the
proficiency of crews
teams and squads advanced unit training
to integrate teams
crews and squads into small units
combined arms training to integrate
infantry armor
artillery engineer and other supporting
units into company and battalion
group exercises and then combat mission
training to
include readiness tests rehearsals of
operational plans and joint
combined training so that's what you're
doing he's saying that same thing over
and over again
you got to train the individual then you
got to train that that next level team
then you got to integrate them with the
other teams then you got to get all
those teams working together
very good way to think about how you
train in any organization you're in
next the need to maintain a high level
combat readiness without peaks and
valleys of proficiency
prevents the commander from
concentrating for long on any cycle
before going into the next this is not
to imply that a unit must perform
all five cycles at one time it does mean
that the commander must elevate
continually
the level of proficiency of his men and
unit in each of these five phases of
training
based on this evaluation he plans his
training program
ideally the commander assesses the
proficiency of each soldier in all five
cycles and organizes his training
so that individuals and the unit as a
whole progressed systematically through
all cycles
and he goes on to explain this and and
what i like about this is how often
with whatever organization you're in or
whatever organization you're leading
do you actually think in a holistic way
comprehensively
about the methodology that you're using
to train your people
the answer is probably not great
so if we don't have even a goal of what
good looks like
if we haven't written down what good
looks like how are we possibly going to
get there
going ahead a little bit based balancing
unit and activities the training
for combat readiness is not the only
mission of the commander
he must also make adequate provisions
for the supply and maintenance of the
unit equipment administration and
discipline
community relations program troop morale
and welfare programs
and the all these activities demand
their share of resources time and
emphasis
so so not only do you have to train
people for combat that's great that's
your number one priority he already said
that
you also got all these other things that
you need to handle which by the way is
the same in any organization
in any organization that you're in guess
what you gotta you gotta take care of
the families
you gotta make sure that your guys are
healthy you gotta make sure that they've
got something to
distract their mind and keep them
occupied
continuing on the immediate day-to-day
pressures of these additional functions
result in a tendency to emphasize
them at the expense of combat readiness
needs
so all of a sudden he just went from
like look you got to take care of those
other things
you gotta get it's like the um
it's like when you it's like when
someone goes you know i just read
you know i read i read in that fitness
magazine that you know rest is even more
important than working out
you know what i'm saying uh and all of a
sudden that becomes the thing
the prevailing mode
is rest yes you know you know what i'm
talking about
do you know what you're talking about
you got that chuckle yeah well you're
over you're looking at me because
you guys said have you ever caught
yourself in that combined arms dilemma
no
where you were kind of like well you
know rest yeah is important
important yeah yes i have
in a way but in this way which might
even kind of apply to this in in as far
as a concept goes
because you use that as the example if
i'm working out or if i don't feel like
working out and i'm like
well i did work out pretty hard
yesterday and rest is important
rationalizing maybe i should rest it's
not like this rest today will hurt me
if anything it'll help me right yeah a
little bit complicated kind of question
or statement
i get it but i'm just saying it's kind
of the same thing where yeah if that
starts to become the because for that
moment it was the prevailing thing
got it so we have to make sure that we
provide ample room for rest and recovery
yes sir but we can't let that become the
prevailing
mode of operating yeah which
let's face it what do people gravitate
towards
people like to gravitate towards that
couch yep the comfort
the fun part the unit commander must
recognize
that even after the elimination of
nice-to-have activities
necessary functions remain which cannot
be fully executed within the resources
available to him
his only recourse is to do first things
first and i got a question like that
today talking to a client well
what do we do when we're resource
constrained what do we do when we don't
have the manpower it's like oh cool yeah
we already talked about did you hear me
talking about prioritizing executed
earlier yeah that's
what we're talking about that's what it
is prioritize and execute
it's interesting too i used to use this
quote
and when i was talking to clients i'd
say there's no organization in the world
that has unlimited resources
we've worked with some companies now
that come pretty damn close to unlimited
at least financial resources they they
have
for all practical purposes unlimited
resources the problem is
the problem becomes human capital right
you can only get you
there's only so many people in existence
that have a certain job skill have a
certain
capability and so that becomes a
limiting factor
so even with a company that has
more money than they can spend
they could throw all kinds of money at
whatever problem they have
but they're limited by
they're limited by human resources and
you could even when you say look we
can pay we can pay you know however many
people a million dollars a year
those people just do not exist and so
and so there is i've had to modify that
a little bit
but the state the statement remains true
there's no
there's no organization in the world
that has
unlimited resources everyone has limited
resources everyone
every company the biggest companies in
the world have limited resources that's
all there is to it
and so what do you always have to do you
always have to prioritize and execute
you always have to prioritize and
execute
he must go what he's there's a part that
i think he's also getting at too is if
you understand what that what that
number one priority is
those other things he talked about and
he kind of did kind of a classic
dichotomy hey this is important
but yeah he also understands that
all those things those morale welfare
recreation type things what they're
actually designed to do
is when we need to come back to that
priority when we need to search for that
most important thing
investing in that is actually the best
way that to have your guys have the
energy
to to exert themselves even more like
i'm kind of thinking about like
surge operations or thinking about you
know when i'm on a deployment we're
supposed to go for six months and we get
the we get the notification
four and a half months into it you're
getting extended for six weeks and this
six month deployment is now going to be
closer to eight months
if you've made that investment in your
family and they
are are all in because you've
demonstrated you care about them you can
do those six
extra six weeks it's no factor but when
you you forsake all these other things
and don't recognize that those things
are important it's really hard to get
anything
extra out of your guys and this is a guy
who's obviously has experience with
we're going to have to exert ourselves
at some point and when that time comes
hey weekends at home with the family
those things aren't going to happen
and the way for that to happen is to
invest in that when you can
when you have the time and resource to
do it knowing that it's going to
actually come back to the thing that
matters the most which is
you going to do your job yeah it's it's
a great correlation to
the rest and recovery that we're talking
for physical working out
if you've got time you need to rest
because there's going to be a time where
there's not going to rest
and you're going to get you're going to
catch a beat down
that's the way it's going to happen
continue on he must analyze his mission
and determine the relative priority and
degree of
interdependence of the functions
essential to mission accomplishment
based on these considerations he must
develop a program of unit activities
which provides a balanced distribution
of resources amongst these functions
so yes you got to take care of your
people to plan such a balanced program a
commander must
first survey his many tasks
in toto
t-o-t-o do you think i looked that word
up like yeah i think he did i sure did
yeah and it's a word totel means
everything means just what it sounds
like it means everything completely
so you gotta look at everything and then
you can do a little prioritize and
execute
and then having made a complete list
listing of appropriate
to his command the commander should
analyze the proportion of
hours and manpower being given to each
activity one method is to calculate the
man hours devoted to each activity
as a percentage of the total man hours
available to the units
a continuous realistic appraisal of the
units
man-hours is an essential part of
command when the commander feels that an
imbalance exists
and that the accomplishment of his
mission is thereby threatened he must
take positive aggressive action to
rectify the situation
when he has exhausted all means at his
disposal without correcting the
imbalance
then he should seek assistance from his
higher commander
that little trick i'll call it a trick
of man-hours
that little trick of when people say
we can't get this done and you go oh
how many man-hours will it take to get
this done
you ask that question because a lot of
times they they've just looked at the
task
and made a made a gut decision
but the problem with that gut decision
is they could be right but it doesn't
help you because you have no
you have nowhere to go because if echo
if i say hey echo
how long it's going to take you to pour
you know to build this block wall
and you say well i don't i can't get it
done i don't have it's going to take way
too long okay well
how long is it going to take how long
would it take one man to do it but just
you by yourself
it would take a week okay so that's 40
hours what if i give you three more
people
you know what i'm saying so digging in a
little bit and figuring out how long it
takes to do something
that's the data that's the data that you
need yeah
he's also telling you don't go back to
your boss and complain hey if you're
under a resource
show them the information hey boss hey
listen you need to get this done it
takes x amount of time x amount of
people
i'm under staff i can't get this done on
time that's a totally different thing
than
jocko dude i can't do this man that's
too hard it's too much work
don't go to your boss and complain if
you don't have what you need no factor
we can address that
but we can only address that if you
actually come back to me with something
that's solvable other than
this is too big of a problem for me yeah
yeah that that is really what it is it's
like
it's it's too big of a problem then i'm
in the mood for
it's like that kind of situation because
you do this all the time even on a small
level
you all start asking those questions
like well well you know
and then wait wait wait wait wait wait
you're being real vague here i know but
i cuz i can't really think of anything
that just gave me that feeling right
when you when when you said hey how long
is this concrete wall gonna take
i was like dang like i know that feeling
where
and i see what you're doing because
you're like hey we like this is a
problem
that needs to be solved to me you know
and
you put some task on me that it's like
bro that's just your idea like bro let's
think
so instead instead of like okay
let's think through the whole thing
really understand what it takes to do it
you know that that process exists no
matter how big and how small
me i just see how big it is or estimate
how big it is and i'm like
i'm really not in the mood for this
right now you know and then you just get
to the bottom of it
so it's kind of like undeniably doable
you know and i'm like
i gotta do this thing man i don't really
yeah there's a
there's a surface level way of looking
at things and just seeing
like what's on the surface and going hey
you know you see the tip of an iceberg
and you go look that iceberg is huge
i can't i can't handle that whole
iceberg it's too it's too big
well let's get a snorkel and mask and
look underwater
and see how much ice is down there that
we got to chip away yeah
that can be done yeah and i kind of
boxed you in sometimes
oh yeah big time even that analogy right
there the iceberg like
i see it you're like okay that's the tip
of the iceberg we know that iceberg is
big
to me i'm like yeah i don't deal with
big icebergs next like just move on and
you're like
okay it's big but you know there's more
to it than that and you're like man i
don't need
i'm not in the mood for all that part
you know you seem saying it's like that
is the difference you know but at the
end of the day it's kind of like
that's how we all are naturally right
where if you see a big task or
let's say you see like a goal right or
something like this and you're like yeah
man i want that
goal i want that you know element of
success or whatever
and then you start like going for it and
you the moment you realize that man this
is gonna take a lot more than i'm in the
mood for
whether it be things get boring or you
realize it's more work or you realize
[ __ ] i gotta learn this
new skill to even get to step two
and i didn't really account for that
when i wanted that thing to begin with
you start to be like oh well it's too
it's too much you know so you so or
even if it gets boring or something like
that rather than analyzing and be like
okay
what would it take to do that oh no i
could have learned this okay let's learn
that and then let's read about you know
step by step
by step and most of the time in the
beginning you're just not in the mood
for all those steps man
you know i you just revealed a pattern
of thought that i have
that i realize that i do all the time
and i think it's actually very important
and i've never really talked about it
before
but i think what it boils down to
i look at things and i
see them or i i will look at them until
i
understand that they are finite
that means that the things are finite
there is
whatever that thing is i will i can get
to the end of it
yeah i can get to i can pull that string
and i will get to the end that that
thing is finite there is nothing
there's nothing that i'm going to find
on earth
to to attack that's infinite
right there's no infinite thing that i
can think of
that i would look at is with a view of
like okay here's something i want to do
oh it's an infinite task no doesn't
exist there's nothing that i'm going to
do that's an
infinite task yeah look at we could we
say it's it's infinite that we want to
continue to learn yes that's an infinite
thing
is it infinite that we want to try and
uh
improve ourselves and get better yeah
that's an infinite thing
is there any particular task that we can
come across
where it's infinite no you get a scuba
mask
you get in the water you dive and you
will find the bottom of that iceberg
and maybe you have to come back up and
get scuba tanks and you have to go down
there maybe you even got to get a mini
sub
but you can find the bottom of that
thing and then guess what you can get it
back up you can grab a little
little pickaxe and you can start
chipping away at that thing yeah
yeah and then and at that point really
at
the end of the day like if you be honest
with yourself you can come to a point
and determine whether or not it's worth
it like if you go down you're like hey
we're trying to move this iceberg
because we want to do this and do that
and whatever right and then you go there
and you're like dang
this is this iceberg is way bigger than
we thought and
it's kind of not worth it our end goal
isn't worth all that what we're gonna
expend you know
think about your difference in mentality
though
when you see that something is finite
yeah that totally changes your attitude
from thinking this thing could go on
forever
because now your your your efforts are
futile
literally futile yeah but once you know
that
there this thing is finite this job has
an end
guess what i'm going to start chipping
and i can i can be persistent and i'm
going to make progress
you know what i don't know if this is
like to the same thing
but you have this thing where you know
the whole idea of like doing something
even though you don't feel like doing it
yes like you don't really have that
like you don't have the you don't have
the opposite you like you don't have
that thing that tells you hey like don't
do it
like if you don't feel like doing it
don't do it if you think it needs to be
done
so having that quality helps that kind
of situation
so like okay i'll apply it to like
working out right
where wait what so what's the thing that
i quote donut don't have
like your behavior changing because you
don't feel like doing something got it
like so you'll be like oh i don't feel
like it but that has nothing to do with
what i'm doing you know so like if
you're about to work out and you're like
man i got this hard workout i got
i got 25 sets till failure today that's
my workout with all these exercises and
all this stuff
if i don't have if i only got one hour
of sleep like that's just not doable for
me
you know the fact that the fact is it is
doable it's gonna suck
but if that's not a factor in your
thinking then you're just gonna do it
you're just gonna
the sucking part is just gonna be part
of the workout kind of thing and it's
going to sort of get done
so if you start thinking like that in
the beginning like start asking yourself
well
we know that it can be done what will it
take to get it done the workout
and then you're like kind of the same
stuff it always
like that's the truth the same stuff it
took last time you know
it'll just suck less and then boom then
you have that finite thing like oh i see
exactly what's making me not want to do
it
and then you sort of gotta admit that to
yourself yeah do you ever have like a
horrible workout
and then you think to yourself well okay
sometimes i'll be staring at whatever
workout and i know it's gonna suck
and you know what you know what i just
realized i do
i go well i'll start now it will be over
in one hour and 20 minutes
yeah if i start right now it's going to
be over i know what i have to do
i'll just turn off my brain it's but it
becomes a finite thing
yeah i make it i use time to put a to
put a
end on it in my mind i won't say oh this
workout's going to suck i'll go oh this
workout's going to suck
it's going to be over an hour and 20
minutes it's done so interesting yeah i
do the exact
i mean essentially it's another version
of that where okay when i first
sort of started out i'd time my rest and
i still do but i can time it in my head
now way better because i'm so used to it
or whatever
um but if i'm like really not feeling
like working out i'll set the timer
right there
so it's like the workout's gonna be done
regardless regardless of what if i don't
set the timer i'll take a little
10 20 second more rest and then it
extends it out more and becomes sort of
this thing
yeah but if you the timer is rolling
right there you're going to do it
whether you feel like because that's
part of the workout you know okay
and then you're done and you're just
done it actually goes quicker the
the one of the hardest moves to make one
of the hardest movements to make in the
gym
is press and start on the stopwatch you
know and i i i do this
i'll write it like in uh i'll write it
on social media i'll be like
him hemden hawed hesitated weighted uh
stretch
some more um get a little more warm like
just per
and it's usually let's face it it's
usually squats where you're like okay
well you know maybe i should just do a
little bit more stretching
maybe i should do a little bit more
overhead squat form with the pvc just to
make sure i'm good and
you do all these things and all you're
doing is just putting it off and then
finally i go okay you know what
shut up and when i go this thing only
ends
when i start it can only end if i start
this thing can only end if i start it
that's a good thing to say
i never tried that one it can only end
if it starts yes
bro i'll do stuff all like organized
little things like oh man that's kind of
messy right there
you know you know
that's good i've never gone that far
dude i might do an extra couple sets of
warm-up but i'm not starting to vacuum
oh that's sketch dude oh man
check all right getting back to the book
everything that i have said about the
balancing of unit activities is doubly
valid for the training program itself
the most
valuable resource available to the
commander is his men's
time and time once lost
can never be regained that's fitting
time once lost can never be regained
poorly
poorly prepared unimaginative or
unnecessary instructions
waste soldiers times worse it is
boring and soon results in ineffective
poorly trained individuals with no
initiative or a spree
the skillful commander is the one who
adopts the philosophy of gainful
employment for each man
and one who takes maximum advantage of
every training hour
to ensure value received
man remember all that
dumb training you did in the military
i do like do when they started
yeah you would just do some training you
just go man this is just horrible
horrible what are we doing it's a waste
in this respect prior preparation and
effective supervision are essential
prior preparation must not be limited to
determining
merely what is material is to be re
merely what material is to be presented
and gathering appropriate training aids
meetings and rehearsals should be held
for appropriate officers and
non-commissioned officers sufficiently
in advance to ensure that the training
preparation
meets the desired standards hey prep
for your training if you're an
instructor
you owe it to the students
nevertheless a commander must realize
that the instructor
is his most important training tool and
that
any time required including duty hours
to prepare that tool for its job
is time well spent the hours given to
preparation and rehearsal of instruction
will be repaid many fold in the hundreds
of man hours that are saved by not
wasting soldiers time
with poorly presented training
totally legit dude don't waste your
people's time
and if you actually want to apply
decentralized command
the best thing you can do with your time
is train your people
it's the best thing you can do
i think we talked about in the last
podcast about how much you learn when
you teach
we're talking about that i think on the
very last one just how
when you become an instructor that's
when you learn the most
man when you have guys on your team that
can train
you want to talk about liberating
yourself to do other things
and people talk about how hard it is to
train your instructor contra how hard it
is to get your people where they need to
be
that is time well spent is training your
trainers
and i mean again everything i i know
he's where he pulls all this stuff from
the experience this guy had in anybody
and you asked me and i just sat there
and just kind of
got depressed hearing anybody that's
ever had their time
wasted by a bad instructor i don't care
if it's in school or anywhere else
we all know that feeling of this is a
waste of my time it's like the most
corrosive thing you can do to somebody
else's waste their time
your instructors your look instructors
is cinnamon
synonym mentors teachers leaders
whatever that's what an
instructor is those are the people that
matter the most in your organization
because they're the ones actually
responsible for other people's time
i i took over trade and i
had a meeting and
i rolled into the meeting and i had like
a wheel book or whatever a little
notebook and i had like four
bullet points of things i needed to tell
the guys and i walked in there and i
told the guys
what i needed to tell them and then i
walked out and like
one of my bros was like dude you came
prepared to this stuff right and i was
like
he's like you come prepared to stuff huh
and i was thinking to myself
well yeah i mean what what's the
alternative what's the alternative to
walk in there and really not know what
the hell you're gonna say
that's crazy that's crazy that's that
you know what that is
that's disrespectful
which i have a problem with
uh there's a chunk in here about safety
obviously
always important we work with a lot of
industries that safety is
is absolutely paramount where lives are
at risk so there's a section there about
safety
the success of any safety program is
dependent on the quality
of support and leadership rendered by
all unit commanders
you know it's like oh we have a safety
officer great that's great that you have
a safety officer
and guess who else is responsible for
safety everyone
training under tactical conditions to me
it is basic that all field training
should be conducted
under tactical conditions setting up an
administrative bivouac
is the easy way out but it is bad
practice and has no place
in the field training of today's soldier
each soldier participating in tactical
training will learn to think and act in
a manner fitting for combat
he'll make mistakes at first but it will
be easier for him to overcome them
in a tactical environment then
it'll be easier for him easier for him
to overcome them in a tactical
environment
than an administrative one realistic
combat habits developed in training will
be second nature
to soldiers in combat poorly trained
soldier
the poorly trained soldier taken by
surprise without a weapon
in his rare in his hand rarely gets a
second chance to amend his habits
so look obvious this the the connection
to the military here is obvious
when you're going to go to the range or
you got range time
don't bring out you know uh an rv
to sit around and play video games while
you're not shooting
go and set up tactical hide sites and
spend time in the field and make the
most of that
the same thing in the business world
right if we're going to train people for
a certain scenario
then do it in the most realistic way
that you maximize the training
after entering combat commanders will
find it's too late to teach
dispersion first aid marksmanship
camouflage care and maintenance of
equipment and the thousand and one other
things that go to make up the
well-trained soldier and unit
it is also a little late to furnish him
an adequate
training background of information
so if you wait it's going to be a
problem
it's the similar thing of people that
think
well you know if i get into a fight like
a real fight right
bro i'll just go full rage you know i'll
go full rage
and they think that that's gonna make up
for 18 years of
jiu-jitsu wrestling muay thai in boxing
right it's not happening you you you'll
lose
there's no there's it's too late you
have to train you have to prepare before
it actually happens
from a leadership perspective isn't it
crazy
isn't it crazy to think that hey
uh i can just roll into a leadership
situation
without any training without role
playing
without thinking through some
contingencies in my mind and things are
just gonna go i'll just know what to do
why would you think that why would you
think that
why would you get that id in your head
why would you get the idea in your head
that if you got to go talk to
you know one of your subordinates that
had an outburst and
and is upset about something why would
you think that just rolling in there
you'll just know what to do
why would you not think through that why
would you not train why would you not
prepare
if you have subordinate leaders that are
working for you
why would you assume that if there's a
contingency that unfolds that they're
just going to figure it out
why would you assume that they're going
to know how to handle when somebody
flies off the off the handle
why would you assume that they're going
to know how to handle when a client
comes in and is
having a having an outburst why would
you assume that they're going to know
what to do
and if they know what to do why would
you assume that they're actually be able
to do it
because that's the next level right is
you can do the moves all day
of muay thai and wrestling but until
you're going against someone
until you spar with someone until you
role play with someone
you're not actually able to do it why
would you assume that the answer is
you'd assume that if you were dumb
don't assume that train
train for those leadership situations
train for those hand-to-hand
combat situations
next section training for good habits
and discipline
in battle the habits and disciplines
that have been instilled in training
are of supreme importance
first because men in combat will do
instinctively what they have been
in the habit of doing in training and
second because only the extra drive of
discipline
will enable the soldier to overcome the
fear that all men
experience in battle
there you go supreme
importance by the way this guy is not
he's not throwing words around
just because they sound good or just
trying to emphasize something
a little bit he's using this word it
might be the only time he uses it
habits and discipline are of
supreme importance
men will do in combat what they have
been in the habit of doing in training
every experience commander knows this
but too often
he fails to appreciate the absolute
necessity of practicing
only correct procedures it is essential
that good habits
be so deeply ingrained in each
individual soldier through correct
teaching and intensive practice
that even under the stress of battle he
will do the right thing
both immediately and instinctively
conversely
because practice makes perfect a
commander must never
under any circumstances permit training
errors to be repeated
there you go to the question of
discipline
i would ask you to consider this more in
the light of
self-discipline because all too often
the word discipline
takes on the connotation of restriction
overbearing authority and blind
obedience
we do not want an automaton
we want an effective combat-ready
soldier who has a keen sense of duty
and who feels an obligation to his
commander to the men around him
and to his unit so anybody that's
questioning you know even me when i'm
saying hey look you get some dna coming
from world war one you get some of that
you get some of that feeling that he's
sort of
hey listen you know the rank structure's
important you better do it yourself
there it is
blind obedience no not what we want
overbearing authority not what we want
restriction on what you're able to do
not what we want what we want is
self-discipline
i'm i'm partially just enjoying
picturing you reading that
and the reaction you had as you're
reading that in general clerk's book for
the first time
the only thing i wrote down i wrote it
down before he said this is the good
news and all this when he's talking
about
the challenge of making real difficult
and realistic training
people like hard training they like
hard training they respond to hard
training and for whatever pushes you
away from
not wanting to make things difficult
that's actually what your people want
when i look back and all the things that
i did the hardest things i did were the
things i enjoyed
the most so whatever you're feeling like
i
the harder it is the better it is
because he talked about the end state of
this is what's going to keep your people
alive and war
for sure but hard training is actually
what your people
want funny you should say that
let me read the next paragraph
instilling discipline in troops is
actually not as difficult as it may
appear
as a matter of fact the answer to
instilling discipline can be given in
one word
training good training overcomes
resistance to obedience and resentment
of authority
so yeah i wrote about this in leadership
strategy and tactics
you want to build morale in a team you
got to do hard things
go through suffering together that will
bring your that will bring your unit
together that will increase your
real morale it will also increase your
discipline yeah
that covers the tangible things it makes
them better at the skill whatever skill
you're training for
but the intangible things like morale
the discipline you just talked about
the esprit de corp the willingness to
take and make sacrifices
that's the intangible qualities that
also come from that as well which is
every bit as important as being really
good at your job
i like this guy one of the keys to
successful training is developing our
men
into the proper attitude toward training
generally our men want to do what we
want them to do and when they don't
it's usually because we have failed to
instruct them properly
that's our fault a guiding principle
that applies to
all units and organizations is that a
man must understand
clearly what is expected of him merely
telling him
is not enough he must be instructed
proper training will also foster pride
and confidence in the individual a pride
and confidence that will be extended to
his leaders
and units as well when that pride and
confidence have been
nurtured to a point that obedience
becomes a habit and response
becomes natural and willing you have
gone a long way towards your
goal of combat readiness as you can see
habit and discipline go hand in hand
a poorly disciplined unit is evidence
that its commander has failed to instill
proper habits through his training
program right from the very start
now again now you feel a little bit of
lean back right
a little bit of lean back to obedience
becoming a habit
and response becomes natural so you get
a little bit of a lean back towards all
right so now we're getting somebody
that's going to be
like obedience is sort of part of that
discipline
even though he said earlier look we
don't want automatons we do not want
automatons that's not what we're looking
for it's not what we're trying to
that's not we're trying to train and
that's the last thing that i want
decentralization of responsibility
once he has set his goals and started
his training program in motion a
commander must rely upon the initiative
of his subordinates
g
by properly delegating responsibility
and the related authority a commander
will foster this initiative and will
enhance the development of all
subordinates officers and
non-commissioned officers alike
i must emphasize here that this
principle cannot be restricted merely to
the training program
but should extend to all unit activities
this is it this is a decentralized
command this is the fourth law of combat
decentralized command it doesn't only
apply to training it doesn't only apply
to
planning it doesn't only apply to
operations it applies to everything
decentralized command is how you need to
operate
how many officers are doing the jobs of
their non-commissioned officers
we speak of enhancing the prestige of
our non-commissioned officers but the
best possible way of doing this is by
giving them responsibility to do the
jobs themselves
while also insisting insisting that they
accomplish
them properly what's giving people
ownership
let them do it try that with your kids
make dinner make tie your own shoes
clean your own room do your own laundry
make them responsible decentralize that
command and
guess what you can do then then you can
focus on getting them better training
this is not to say that the commander
should abdicate his own responsibility
but a one-man shop of is a one-man shop
is
evidence of poor leadership there you go
so if you're running everything bad
leadership
a good commander will patiently and
carefully instruct his subordinates to
ensure they know what is expected he may
even have his subordinates
return and present their plans for
accomplishing the tasks
but he will then insist that they get
the jobs done
without detailed guidance so again now
we're back to like this leaning back
towards hey i'm not going to tell you
exactly what to do look i i want
obedience but you go figure out what you
want to do
so he's balancing this dichotomy of
leadership
between hey you need to put some
structure in place so people know what
to do but i still want you to go and
figure out how to how you're going to
get it done
it's almost like you have to take the
word obedience
and and change what that natural
reaction you have is because i hear the
word obedience i don't like that word
there's a
i don't like that word and just like you
described i actually don't
i don't want my people to feel like they
have to be obedient to me
and so it's almost as if the obedience
isn't i say to do something and you do
it it's the obedience is
it's the natural almost unspoken
reaction that what we need to get done
is going to get done
as opposed to you will do what i say
because that
if that's the obedience you're looking
for you actually just hurt you're just
hurting yourself
in so many different ways but there's
there's language in here when i hear you
say it might
kind of get that little like oh i don't
i don't like that but as he explains it
and kind of peels that back
the obedience he's referring to isn't i
demand you to be obedient to my orders
it's
i want and when he talks about
decentralization
i want the obedience to be we're going
to solve this problem we're going to get
whatever needs to get done i'm actually
going to have you figure it out half the
time
yeah and i think to take what you just
said and to take it one step further
what obedience is and it's
everything he is saying is is leading to
towards the result of
what obedience is if you're obedient
you're driving towards accomplishing the
mission
that's it that's my obedience we got a
mission and i'm going to accomplish it
that's what i'm going to do yeah because
he's literally saying without detailed
guidance i'm not going to tell you how
to do it here's the mission go
accomplish it that's obedience
by giving them responsibility and
authority and by
underwriting their honest mistakes
he will encourage them to exercise
initiative and accept responsibility
he will help them to develop into more
effective individuals and hence
into more effective soldiers and
officers this in turn will result in a
better unit
that sentence right there
giving respon giving responsibility and
giving authority
and underwriting their mistakes like hey
you made a mistake hey god i got it no
problem
there's no problem you're you're you're
encouraging them that's how you create
leaders that are going to take
initiative which is exactly what you
want
if you're a good leader a problem arises
when
individuals are given the authority to
make decisions on various types
of actions and then fail to use it how
much time is wasted by
passing the buck to the next level even
though authority existed to make a
decision on the spot
training supervision proper supervision
of training still remains primarily the
commander's responsibility
a good model to bear in mind is an
organization does well only things the
boss checks he's
he goes over that over and over again he
talks about inspections again here we
covered that on one of the
earlier podcasts and one thing he
he does say and i'll just re-emphasize
it a word of caution
is in order inspections that are poorly
scheduled or executed
will harass the troops and if you're
harassing the troops with your little
freaking inspection
you're wrong you're wrong that's not
what inspections are for
training methods proper methods of
training will produce
better soldiers in less time and hence
speed the building of combat-ready units
a discussion on training methods
invariably includes a question of
the committee system versus the unit
method of training
which is better probably a combination
of the two methods at the lowest
practical level
of command is the best answer
decentralized command
small unit commander should be
responsible for the bulk of training
although specialized subject or those
involving a small segment
of several units often lend themselves
to centralized instruction by committee
so that's
all good stuff if you've got some
universal skill that everyone needs to
learn
hey send people to a schoolhouse for
that we get that
and you know he goes in
through these things
talks about some bad practices as well
bad practices
such as having men wait in line to run a
lane on the assault course
or having men wait behind the ready line
to fire on the range
you gotta eliminate those things he says
and he says it cannot be emphasized too
often that a man learns
best by doing
in every appropriate subject or element
of training practical application
must be stressed got to do
sometimes i would get these instructors
i remember especially going through
close quarters combat training you know
so clearing rooms and in the beginning
when you're taking a task unit through
the instruction of room clearances you
know you start at a very fundamental
basic level
and guys are doing one and two man room
entries that's they start off or
sorry two man room entries
and so it's like i would get basically
maybe take two platoons to do two
different sections of the kill house and
one of the instructors
would be a guy that would focus on
really explaining things a lot
going into a lot of detail maybe
maybe like to hear himself talk a little
bit the other person maybe is a guy
that's
like hey here's what you got to do all
right let's start running let's start
doing it
and by the end of the day i'd have to
switch the platoons because the platoon
that was doing would be way ahead of the
platoon that was listening
you have to freaking do stuff yeah you
have to freaking do stuff
would you write down um
i mean you got to remember too i'm
sitting here listening as you're talking
about it and i'm hearing it
from you through him for the first time
connecting it to the things that i've
experienced
and i'm hearing all these little there's
all these common things he keeps coming
back to he's talking about not wasting
people's time he's talking about pushing
decision making down
he's talking about giving your people
authority and responsibility
and then taking ownership of their
honest mistakes
a great way to not waste your people's
time
is to not have them be reliant on you to
make decisions for them
and as you push that decision making
down your subordinate leaders get closer
and closer to the problem
and their ability to solve those
problems and do things that are
constructive and useful for their people
is them not being reliant on you and
why i wrote it down is he asked the
question beginning he said
how many officers are doing the jobs of
their non-commissioned officers
how many leaders are making decisions
and doing things on your team in your
organization right now
that you really shouldn't be doing and
the answer is probably almost all of you
and if you can just have a mental
exercise of let me just think for a
minute of any task that i do
that i really shouldn't be doing if
you're doing that you are wasting your
people's time you're hindering their
development
find a task that you shouldn't be doing
and push it down to them
and then when they screw it up take
responsibility and ownership for it
train them better
resource them better but as you push
those decisions making
push that decision making down you waste
less of their time
and just i'm just hearing him connecting
all these things together
and how crazy it how simple it sounds
when he says it
but how often we don't do the very thing
he's describing
and isn't it strange that this is a guy
that spent 45 years in the military and
it
well 45 years in the military whatever
50 years ago
and actually a hundred years ago because
he he he was
got in in 1917 so
103 years ago and he spent his whole
life in the army
multiple wars but what we're talking
about you and i
we definitely apply it to we reflect on
our time in the military and
we reflect on businesses right now in
every single industry that we work with
all the time
we talk to on a daily ba how many
companies do you talk to a day
three four five different companies a
day yeah every day me too
and personnel at different levels inside
those companies and
all these things apply all these things
apply
universal there are universal truths to
leadership
there really are universal truths to
improvement through ideas research and
development the army is constantly
seeking ways and means to improve the
training of the individual
as well as to develop and improve
equipment and procedures research into
new
and more modern methods and ideas is a
continuing
process various organizations both
military and civilian devote all their
energies to prod
to projects of a research nature and he
goes on
talking about that applying well as to
establish scientific principles to
military problems these groups observe
the test individuals and units over a
period of time to determine the best
method
of performing a specific operation or
the advisability of adopting a specific
item being studied so he's he looks at
things
not saying hey i got the answer that's
him saying look we gotta you gotta
bring in experts that actually can study
and see what the right answer is
commanders should always encourage
imagination and ingenuity seeking better
ways to solve
their training maintenance and
management problems
next section chapter 9 training the
individual
adjusting the soldier to his new career
the individual begins his military
career in an army training center or in
a selected unit
to the new soldier this is the front
door
to the army here he gets his first taste
of military life
this is where he is indoctrinated in the
fundamentals of military service
and where he forms the thoughts ideas
and habits that stay with him throughout
his service
and that go with him when his service is
terminated
from this starting point in his career
the soldier will develop
in proportion to the effort made to put
him
on the right track and to the
application of sound training practices
during this vital period of adjustment
this is something that i absolutely saw
all the time and i don't know if you
would
i don't know if this would apply to uh
flying jets
but what you learn what guys learn in
their first seal platoon
they always are biased towards that as
being the right thing
doesn't matter if it was right or wrong
archaic or not new old they
would they learned in that first platoon
they always
i know i always was and i had to fight
against that unnatural bias or natural
bias that i would have towards
hey well you know this is what i learned
this is the way you do it
i guess the first thing you learn leaves
the deepest
the deepest scars the deepest trail
does that happen with flying jets
totally man you show up in your first
squadron and the things that that the
more experienced guys are saying is
gospel
and it's probably not a lot different
for you you know
most guys that did what i did we spent
our whole lives dreaming about doing it
and by the time you finally got your
first squadron
which was the the top of the mount
you've been climbing your whole life
everything there is what is everything
that's said there is gospel because you
made it to where you wanted to be and
these guys that have been there are
telling you
that stuff is seared in your brain and
the truth is
it's not all right a lot of it is is not
right and
it's really hard to undo those bad
habits
same thing happened to me i got there
first squash and people are talking that
is burned into my brain
is there anything that you learned in
your first squadron that later you were
like wow i learned that the wrong way
yeah a lot you and leif do this a lot
when you when you tell stories about
what was unique about
task unit bruiser and the uniqueness of
that was
was a lot less about the tactics and the
maneuvers that you executed
and and the weapons and things like that
it was so much more about the culture
the mindset and the
and the the recognition of ownership and
leadership being
the thing that's going to make you
unique what i
learned or looked back on in my in my
the lessons of my first quadrant
i certainly learned some things like hey
that's not the best way to run the
system or the best way to maneuver your
aircraft
but what i learned the most in
retrospect was the leadership
that was either good or bad and it's
really hard to diagnose bad leadership
when you're a really
young guy at least initially you'll show
up and kind of whatever's going on there
like okay this is how it is cool and you
kind of get on board
and it's actually connected to to a note
that i wrote when you were talking about
people walking in the front door we may
think we've got a lot of time
with those new folks but they start to
form those opinions very quickly you
know the first couple days are just kind
of clueless they're just going to get on
board
but very quickly they're going to start
to take note of what's going on around
them
and they're going to acclimate to
whatever type of leadership you give
them
and if there's good leadership they're
going to they're going to align with
that and if it's not
they're gonna align with that too and so
the clock that you're running with these
new folks
they start to move to whichever
direction you push them
very very quickly and my
what i look back on is the lessons that
i learned i look back like man
i thought that squadron was really good
and it really wasn't
we didn't do a lot of these things that
we should have been doing and it's
mostly centered around the things you've
always talked about about
hey you know what when we take our
squadron up to fallon for for three
weeks for a big fallon airwing debt
you know what we're doing on friday
nights everybody's going out to the bars
on friday nights
and that's what we did and when i was in
squadrons units that
they didn't do those things because they
knew that they had limited window for
training and they're gonna stay
and and and get better
that's when the contrast became much
more clear about the things that i'd
grown up with that weren't nearly as
good as i thought they were at the time
and look man when you're on the other
side and you tell these stories about
trade when you've seen
10 000 runs of the same clearance
literally just thousands upon thousands
it becomes very easy to see
what good and bad looks like yeah the
the the pid the positive identification
of good and bad
man i don't know why i was paying
attention to that stuff when i was a
young
frog man and it was
you know we we showed up in the 90s man
we showed up in the 90s
and the 90s was
after the 80s and i know that might
sound funny but
it's important because the 80s
there was basically no war
i mean most of the 70s yeah
so think about that you know like the
last seal platoon
in the early 70s was a 72 73 something
like that last seal platoon there's a
couple more stragglers over there
but then you go 70 then you go all the
way to 1980 then you go all the way from
80 to 90
and you had look you had grenada a
handful of guys you had panama
handful of guys and by a handful you
know 50 guys whatever the number is
but it's a very tiny percentage of the
community
and then you roll into the 90s but i'm
coming off the 80s
so understanding what it meant
to be combat ready was
a faded picture it was a
faded picture and there were some guys
that knew and thank god
thank god some of those old vietnam guys
were there thank god some of the
second some of the people that had
learned firsthand from the vietnam guys
they were there to to to hold that line
but there was also guys that were sure
you know we ain't going to war
we ain't going to war we're going
drinking
totally you know we that's what yeah and
even if we're not going drinking you
know what we're we're not going
we're not going to war we're going to
hang out with our family we're going to
go run some side business we're going to
go
do other things besides just be a team
guy
and and that's a weird place to come
from it's a weird place to roll into the
teams when you have these expectations
like i had the
i had the dumbest expectations you know
i thought i was going to nom
thought i was going enough in 1991
i was ready to freaking deploy to da
nang you still think
i still kind of do think that man
whenever i talk to tilt
those guys i remember asking tilt like
was it hard to vlog
no maybe it was maybe it was dick
thompson i was like was it hard because
he volunteered for this volunteered for
that
and i said was it hard to volunteer he
was like no
they were like oh you want to go to
special force that's cool right over
here
oh you want to go to sog cool right over
here oh you want to be an officer cool
right over here you step right oh yeah
we got openings man we got openings why
do we got openings we got openings
we have more than 100 percent casualty
rating
more than 100 casualty rating if you
show up here you will be wounded or
killed how's it going
yeah there's the line
and those tilt frenchmen dick tom
just rolling in just yeah good let's do
it what do you got
we can't tell you about it cool i'll
sign up when i put my name
don't do the titles for the song
episodes
of this podcast dead man walking
don't don't go to sog that's what that
was the word that was the gouge did you
use that term the gouge
yeah totally that's the gap that was the
gouge don't go to salt
don't go to sog and these guys are like
well why wouldn't we go to sog everyone
gets wounded or cool
killed oh cool sign me up yeah
so i thought i was going to nom
so when i get to the team and and
the you know what i had to do with
vietnam i got vietnam issue
vietnam era h gear that was left over
from thom
i got that you couldn't tell the
difference when you saw me going through
sqt my like the the gear that i used was
vietnam gear
like that's the same gear the same
canteens the same mag pouches everything
was the same
so i kind of was going to novel
but that impression that you get in that
first platoon
man it leaves a mark yeah
it leaves a mark and so that's why if
you're in a leadership position and
you've got people
checking on board you've got to
recognize that you're making a mark
don't play around with that
essential to the smooth and orderly
transformation of the individual from a
citizen to a soldier is the organization
and caliber of the training
establishment
the commander of this training activity
must be given the tools to work with and
enough priority to ensure assignment of
the most competent officers and men
personnel should be carefully selected
highly motivated and imbued with the
standards prescribed for
basic combat training a prerequisite for
later command
has its foundation in this criteria
until an officer a noncommissioned
officer has served in these capacities
he is handicapped in the art of training
units that's powerful
how often is it that we actually invest
our best people into being instructors
not often enough not often enough you
guys do it
the top gun does it yeah well i was
thinking that you guys do it as well
i mean the parallels between what you
did in trade this is the thing
when i got into the teams no one wanted
to go to training
it was hey man i don't want to go over
there i want to go on deployment
yeah i want to go to nam i want to go on
deployment that's what everybody wanted
to do
part of the reason was because one of
the ways that you got cred
street yeah was by doing deployments
right hey i did three deployments i did
four deployments i did five deployments
you were in a pecking order there was a
packing order so nobody wants to get out
of that cycle they just want to go on
deployment deployment deployment because
you want to
you want to go up that hierarchy you
want to be five platoons
you want to be seven do you want to do
as many platoons as you can as fast as
you can
it's kind of funny because when the you
know you'd be a new guy in your first
platoon
but then i was talking to a
nom guy and he was like
you're a new guy until you go into
combat
so all you [ __ ] are cherries
it's like roger that this dude's sitting
there with six deployments under their
belt
but they never went to war so he's just
like yeah cherries
whatever yeah cherry boys whatever keep
keep it up
man what a life trainer personnel will
face many problems with their new
soldiers trainees come from every aspect
of life
so this is what i think the reason i
wanted to cover this part is because
we work with companies all the time they
hire people all the time
what's your indoctrination program how
are you welcoming them aboard
what are you doing to train them out of
the gate oh you gotta
you're so critical to get them in the
role that you can't spare
four days to set aside and get them
trained up and familiarize and meet them
with the right people
you can't do that it's more important
that you just get them
totally blind rolling into their role
that doesn't make any sense man set
aside some time
trainees come from every walk of life
all kinds of schooling other civilian
experience
multitude of aptitudes beliefs skills
from this
complex mixture of raw material the
training unit commander
has to turn out trained soldiers who are
ready to undergo further training and
ultimately become combat ready fighters
in the army's
combat ready units
during this period of his training this
new soldier will have to learn how to
live as a soldier with other soldiers
he will learn to accept discipline to
keep him physically fit
to develop proper habits of eating
sleeping recreation
and sanitation and to live harmoniously
with his fellow soldiers
these things will not come easily to all
trainees many will need lots of help
and lots of guidance to overcome their
troubles their commanders the ones who
can and should give this assistance
isn't that weird to think about
this is where you're going to develop
these people that have just they're
they're just random
i know i never uh i always joke about
the fact that i
i never flossed my teeth until i joined
the navy
and in boot camp they're like you need
to floss your teeth every night i was
like okay
whatever i've never i've lost my teeth
every night since then
i was just a savage that didn't floss my
teeth
but that's one of the many habits where
they this is what you do this is what
you're supposed to do cool roger that
i'm that kid
of course i can floss some of my teeth
with like a piece of rope
although new soldiers are being trained
as replacements for other units all
training commanders will do well
to look at their trainees this way these
are my
men i will train them as if i'm going to
fight alongside them and as if my life
will someday depend be in their hands
that's it that's that's that is one cool
thing that you hear from guys that
worked as buds instructors
is the attitude of like hey this i do i
want this guy in a platoon with me right
that's a great place to start
that criteria is is is so important i
mean
yeah top gun we talked about a little
bit maybe a difference there was there
was a key in
uh emphasis put on training in my
community topkin was obviously
a place that resembled the
reflected that that apex of that
training
facility if you want to call it that but
really what it was there was a chance to
pass on information to to teach guys and
the criteria for finishing that program
was if you as an instructor who was
gonna
if i'm gonna put that top gun patch on
your shoulder the criteria was
would i go to war with you that was the
criteria is this guy
someone that i would go to war with as
his wingman and
again you've talked about it it may be a
little bit more
evident in the military example because
we're talking about literal war
we're talking about a guy who's written
something based on his experiences in
war
but the translation to anywhere in the
private sector or even your own family
isn't that hard
if you think about what is the criteria
that really matters to you what you'd be
willing to do with or for this person
it doesn't have to be war as the outcome
and you're talking about you know the
investment you're making
in your people up front you can you
spare can you spare a week to put this
person on the right path
so his his ability to be successful in
the organization is
a hundred times greater than if you just
shoved him out there because
we're understaffed or we got to get this
job done go get that person in the role
yeah
gotta make the the investment that you
make up front
will be tenfold then not making it
next section is entitled the army is
built on discipline
when a man comes into the army he
usually leaves home for the first time
he leaves behind his parents his friends
the inhibitions he has built up from
being around those who have been close
to him
without the the restraining influence of
these inhibitions
and in the quick tempo of his new life
as a trainee he is likely to slip
in morals in neatness and in
energy the one thing that will keep him
on the right track
is discipline development of discipline
is the best way to re-institute the
desirable
inhibitions he may have lost how can
commanders instill discipline in their
trainees
the answer can be given in one word
training this is a rehash right
good training overcomes resistance to
obedience and resentment of authority
when obedience becomes habit
and is natural and willing training is
paid off in terms of disciplined
soldiers
development of discipline can be part of
every period of training during basic
training commanders have
many opportunities to stress the
importance of these things which take
which make a disciplined soldier
obedience alertness neatness of dress
and physical fitness
the trainee will also develop a respect
for commanders and a renewed devotion to
his country
in battle discipline is of supreme
importance this is
let's see the only time you use the word
supreme
most men are afraid in battle but
discipline produces the courage to
overcome this fear discipline is a
in a soldier implies a sense of duty and
obligation to his unit
when the soldiers of a unit share that
obligation the unit has gone a long way
toward the goal of combat effectiveness
only one kind of discipline is
acceptable it is perfect discipline
when trainees show evidence of poor
discipline it is generally because their
commanders have failed to insist on
perfect discipline from the start
and that's patent that's a patent quote
only one kind of discipline
that's perfect discipline
he talks about getting to an overseas
environment
the new arrival should be indoctrinated
in the customs of the new country in
which he is stationed he should be
encouraged to meet his new neighbors
learn their ways study their language
become familiar with their history
and then he talks so i'm going to skip
forward a little bit too
well i got to cover this one this one
other little section
simultaneously with his with his new
geographical environment must come
adjustment to his new situational
environment
the transformation is one of attitude in
which the new arrival must be made to
realize he is no longer in a basic
training or garrison situation
he must now apply the training
principles and garrison experience he
has gained
he must be made aware of the seriousness
of his situation
that he is in the front line of defense
against aggression
while there are many educational and
recreational diversions overseas the
commander must keep
the new arrival constantly alert to the
necessity of keeping himself combat
ready
the astute commander must be
not only a leader and trainer of men
but a student of psychology and
human nature as well
he must be able to instill in his men
the feeling that they can enjoy their
tours of duty overseas benefit from the
experience and at the same time be
prepared to assume
more serious endeavors when called upon
so there you go you gotta understand
human nature
you gotta understand a little psychology
motivation for performance it has been
said that
man is the army's most valuable asset
even
the greatest asset however becomes a
liability if
improperly used the american soldier
must be properly motivated before
he will efficiently and willingly
perform his assigned tasks
from this motivation develop esprit
enthusiasm
morale effort competition and
accomplishment
when i mean motivation of the american
soldier overseas is best accomplished
when he number one
knows why he is there
that's the number one thing the number
way number one way to make sure
someone's motivated make sure they know
why they're doing what they're doing
same answer i give nine times a day
is made to feel that he belongs is
performing
primarily a job for which he has been
trained
knows where his efforts fit into the big
picture
is recognized and rewarded for success
the one of those that i would say was a
was a new thought in my mind was that
is performing primarily in a job for
which he's been trained and i was kind
of like
that's a good point that's a good point
think about when you're when you're
doing something you're like oh yeah
this is what i've been that's what i
learned you know in jiu-jitsu it's real
clear right
oh i learned this escape and you use it
that's just a total reward
yeah how about when you learn some new
technical skill on the film making
and then you get to apply it sometimes
you got to force it in there
in many cases yeah it's like you'll do
it yeah just because you're pursuing
that very thing right that you're
talking about
yeah so when it comes naturally when it
naturally occurs it's a super positive
thing
big time dave how long were you in the
marine corps
for before you dropped a bomb on target
from an f-18
uh six years six years
did that feel good it did yeah did that
give you motivation
it's crazy how to do the math there i
was thinking man how long was it
it was six years what year did you get
commissioned 94.
and then you dropped bombs bomb you
singular you
in 2000 yeah listen like you said man
remember
this is you were straight up you were
straight up like top gun
experiencing the mig right like maverick
and maverick have the close flyby with
the mig i'm saying that because
because in 2000 how many people
i look i don't know if it's fact
but if it's not fact it's really close i
was like the first guy in
the world to drop a j damn because i had
my squadron on deployment was the first
squadron that had
gps good deal dave burke is coming in
hot
but at the time spent billions of
dollars developing this weapon system
and you're the guy that gets to drop it
again okay
do you remember the date um no but it
was a month
it was april of 20th 2000 okay so april
of 2000 we're going out there
just just canvassing the world if
there's anyone out there that knows
anyone
that dropped the j damn before april of
please let us know so i can put this guy
over here a good deal david
check yes put him in check
it's like you said though man i mean
first of all at the time
for me that was it dude we're done
checking the block i can i can die a
happy man it's because of what you said
there wasn't anything going on i mean
you look back now
you know post 911 it's it's i mean it is
it's embarrassing i don't even like we
talk about this all the time i don't
even like bringing it up
but at the time that was it and
and to get back to your your more
serious point of dude was i stoked
i i never felt
more useful in what i was doing than
that night i can picture it hitting that
pickle switch and that bomb coming off
my jet blowing up that
that sa-3 launcher in iraq
that was like the most important thing
i'd ever done in my life how many people
did that after you drop yours
did things start to escalate well no we
were you just get the one
good deal dave burke look man it was
kind of a cool thing at the time it
really was and yeah if
if i'm if i'm if i'm out of turn let me
know uh there's just not that many
people out there that that is that
have the potential of doing it given the
systems that were required when the bomb
hit the fleet and everything
it was a confluence of a lot of things
that just went my way
so you're saying that in the whole fleet
the jade dam had just kind of arrived
first of all the jdm had just arrived
and what was required is a gps
aircraft on my carrier there was one
squadron that had gps on board
which was that yes in your aircraft
aircraft the other aircraft the other
four squadrons
couldn't even carry the weapon and this
was the first time
yes and marine corps got it before navy
no it's not that the marine corps got it
just so happens out of my deployment the
three
the navy squadron of fighters they
didn't have gps aircraft
which is kind of crazy but we did so
again so you dropped the first ever j
dam
like i said if it wasn't the first it
was really close it was definitely the
first one
what about what about uh what about
bosnia
what about sarajevo that's i'm i'm
almost positive that predates gps guided
weapons that's all laser guided some
other other guidance systems that's not
gps guided weapons
you're going out on the limb i am and
look fix it if i'm wrong
dial in send a message i'll be happy to
give you
damn's hitting your brain yeah maybe
when there's some guys that flew into uh
sarajevo dropping bombs yeah well i mean
look i could definitely be wrong
uh at the time i wasn't like do you know
i'm gonna add this to like
your bio when i talk about you
because you know i got my little you
know hey he was this he was that and i'm
gonna say he also dropped the first
ever j damn the first ever gps guided
munitions
was dropped by colonel dave burke
the two thousand pound jdm and tooth in
the year 2000
was this brand new incredible thing that
we just got trained on which
it was kind of what were the
circumstances that got you cleared hot
yeah the circumstances were you know
during the day uh
i was scheduled for like a night mission
just a a pre-scheduled mission
that probably involved you know a
handful of airplanes doing
operation southern watch just kind of
monitoring the airspace which we did
i was on deployment right on
i was on deployment yeah i was about to
head home what aircraft carrier were you
coming off of the stennis
was the jfk did you replace the james
replaced the jf i was on the jfk
so i guess i missed you that's as we're
talking
that's the other carrier that would have
had the potential
i think there was only one squadron on
that carrier the other marine horn
squadron might have had the chance so
there if it's going to happen it's going
to be off that carrier
but between the jfk and us during that
you know spring to summer of 2000 which
was just
monitoring the no-fly zone what happened
was in the middle of the day on a day
that i happen to be
already hard scheduled we got triggered
what's called
an ro a response option which means
saddam did something that met some
criteria that we had a
pre-planned response to and what he
happened to do in this case was took a
sam launcher south of
you know the the the parallel the the
line that we were
that we were responsible for so intel
says hey they moved to sam site down
south of where
they're not allowed to be here below
this line they can't be here and
the big debate was so we got this
information this intelligence
the debate was hey we're not going to
let the brand new guy go on this mission
this is a response option that mandates
we're going to go blow this thing up and
my squadron commander was like
negative that's the schedule he's going
flying
and if it wasn't wait you were a new guy
i was it
was this your first performance yeah my
first cruise my first deployment
and the only reason i was on there was
just you know every fourth or fifth
night you just ended up on the schedule
i was
you know dash whatever of this of this
mission it turns out that my flight lead
yeah i'll tell you i look i'm i'm i'm
all about being fair and everything
if i was the squadron commander or the
squadron xo
or the ops officer or one of the others
or anybody else in the squad
uh that new guy just broke his left heel
yeah he got heal
weird i don't know what happened but i'm
taking his place
dude it was one of those things that the
air wing
had scheduled responsibility to cover
the no-fly zone i was on the schedule it
was going to be a totally boring night
mission which we'd done all the time was
just covering the no-fly zone
middle of the day this happened we knew
that that package that was going in was
going to go from a
a monitoring mission to a targeting
mission
the the mission loadout required
a gps guided weapon there happened to be
one aircraft in that formation from one
squadron that had the gps
aircraft and gps guided weapon i was
there i was scheduled for that
there was a behind-the-scenes
conversation i was not part of over
whether this new guy chip was gonna get
to go
because this is garbage because he's
brand new the squadron commander was
like i'm not building a habit pattern by
which
because of the mission i'm gonna change
the formation he's a young guy he could
go do it i went and did it i launched i
joined on the wing of
of some other squadron aircraft we flew
north for two and a half hours
i blew this thing up and i came home
were you nervous
i was ex yeah but not like
i was nervous but not like were you
super confident i knew that
i was i was nervous and stoked a gps
bomb i mean is this a hard job no it is
not a hard thing to do
as a matter of fact the beauty of this
mission just to put things in context is
that
before i even got into my airplane i was
handed the precise latitude and
longitude which i pre-programmed into a
basically a disc that i downloaded to
the airplane so before i even
took off from the carrier i my aircraft
and the bomb
all knew exactly where to go it was
literally i'm just carrying this thing
on my wing my only job was to arm it up
and press the button
do you did you fly flat dumb and happy
like at a certain altitude or did you
go come on did you kind of like hey bro
i would love to tell you the coolest
story in the world
it's not a cool story like i told you
telling the story now is
almost embarrassing because people
listening now when they think about what
we have done
since 2001 this story is
the least exciting combat story you'll
ever hear and combat should be in quotes
in 2000 it was the coolest thing i had
ever done we did uh we did a bunch of
shipboardings
in the on that deployment yeah so in the
millennium deployment between 2000
1999 and 2000 we did like shipboardings
overseas and one of the shipboardings
that we happened to do
was of a big russian oil tanker
and it was on cnn and all this kind of
stuff so it was kind of the big mesh
kind of the same thing and just to put
it in perspective when we got back so we
were on the carrier
and then there was another platoon from
team two that was on the arg
and when we got back we had to like
brief
the ceo and the commodore about like
what we did on deployment
and so we got to brief you know that we
did this thing which was kind of
you know at the time was pretty cool and
just to put it in perspective
what the other platoon commander briefed
was that they did
an inextremist uh
propeller clearance for the arg ship
like something got tangled in the
propeller and they like
anchored the ship and they dove down and
like cut the thing off and they kind of
like helped
that was what they proved that's what a
seal platoon did in you know
night in the year 2000 and that was the
highest level thing that they did with
the most visibility that they could
debrief
was we did a maintenance dive
on the ship we were on on board yeah so
that just kind of tells you
how what it was like at the time were
different back then man
so i'm 100 i can
totally uh imagine what you were
feeling going into this and coming out
of it
yeah it was it was awesome at the time
and
look when i came back i mean the whole
ship knew about it
um there was a press release that i have
a copy of somewhere
that that the iraqi media put out
that you know uh uh i honestly think it
was like straight up
a baby milk factory had been attacked
you know the standard propaganda
you know unarmed civilians were killed
the whole story i got in the into
officer kingdom hey check this out this
is the report from your attack
i've got all the stuff somewhere into
your mom totally yes
absolutely so it was um it was an
interesting time
it was a time that i had obviously none
of us knew what was coming you know i
didn't know the following year
how much things would change and i
actually thought at that time
that was probably the only chance i was
ever really gonna have
to do something that contributed to the
mission which is exactly how i felt
i felt like i finally did my job after
a lifetime of dreaming about it and six
years training for it
little did i know that's awesome
yeah so if you're in uh if you're in cag
nine
on the stennis or if you're in cag two
on the jfk which was 251 was the marine
hornet squadron
let me know if i got my facts not
straight
but at that time there was just not a
lot going on jfk did some work to ship
your own too
they dropped some bombs they did but
maybe not gps guided i don't think so
like it really matters but call me out
okay
it did at the time bro i can tell you it
didn't at the time
check uh legit yeah
he goes through looking at these these
these
items to to
motivate keep someone motivated
um first of all
a man does any task better when he
thoroughly
understands the reasons for performing
that task
surely you have heard the question what
am i doing here
what have you the commander done to
answer this question
have you made your troop information
program merely a corner bulletin board
in the day room
have you explained to your men the role
of allied forces in your overseas area
as part of the united states army
and what it plays in that role have you
discussed with them the threat of
communism
have you shown them how an alert
well-trained strong force in peacetime
becomes a deterrence to aggression and
armed conflict
so that's the why
yeah and that's the why that we talk
about all the time
go ahead yeah do they understand how
what they're doing contributes to the
mission
yeah it's as simple as that yeah and
when you're working on the front lines
of
a factory look
if you understand how that contributes
to everything that's happening and
and what we're trying to do that that
makes a difference
the only way they're ever going to know
that is if their leadership makes that a
priority
or else they're going to get stuck down
there and their perspective of the world
is going to get smaller and smaller
they're going to feel more and more
disconnected and they're not going to
understand it you have to make that
happen
that will not happen on its own that's
one thing that's cool uh
up at origin you know
the the troops that are on the front
line
they see what's happening
right down to the fact that they can see
people competing in their geese
right they can see people working in the
genes that they made they get thank yous
they get
you know uh pictures of the genes being
worn
in north dakota being worn in texas
being you know being used and it's
awesome
and they know that that they can feel
what that means because it's bringing
back the community
and so everybody understands that why
it's so important pete does a great
job making that clear
the second item i outlined as a
motivation force is a sense belonging
very few drives of a man are stronger
than his desire for identification with
a group
when he knows what that he has wanted he
has a definite niche a specific
job and that his efforts contribute to
the achievement of common goal
then he becomes proud of himself his
unit and his superiors
develop your men developing your men
this feeling of identification
and your task will be lighter then when
the chips are down and they are called
upon to do battle they will perform as
members of an integrated team
not as individuals this brings us to the
utilization demand and this is what this
is this is
the story of dave burke thousands of
dollars were spent to train each man
first as a basic soldier then as a
specific mos is
each man in the unit doing being used in
the job for which he was trained
i realize only too well that commanders
must occasionally put men off their jobs
to meet temporary requirements
the men realize the necessity for this
too too often however a commander
forgets to put the man back in the job
for which he's trained the men do not
understand this
and such action is often demoralizing
and results in the loss of unit
effectiveness when it becomes necessary
to assign an individual to a position
other than the one for which he has been
trained
the commander will rise in stature if
proper counseling is given
explain why the temporary assignment has
been made
and let that man know as soon as
possible he will be reassigned to duty's
commensurate with his mos
one thing should be kept in mind however
no amount of motivation will make a man
tackle his job he knows is too big for
him
that's the infinite thing
where a man fits into the big picture
obviously important and then
goes into that a little bit and finally
there's a great deal of vanity in each
of us
and few things are more motivating than
recognition for a war
and reward for a job well done
he then jumping forward a little bit
he's got a little section on physical
fitness which i always like to cover
the vision of a push-button war suggests
that the physical rigors of the
battlefield belong to the past
isn't that crazy 1963 he's thinking that
just think of that
nothing could be farther from the truth
physical fitness in today's army is even
more important than it has been in the
past and
this is especially true in overseas
theaters where to meet any communist
block aggression
the fighting man on the ground is the
ultimate weapon the fundamental factor
of the decision
the soldier overseas must be combat
ready not only
in terms of equipment training and
conviction but also in terms of ability
to withstand the rugged demands of
physical combat
the time to begin is the day a new
physical a new replacement arrives
in your command in many cases he will be
fresh from basic or advanced individual
training
and it will merely be a matter of
maintaining his high state of physical
fitness that he brings with him
in other cases you may well have to
start from scratch and bring the man
up to the desired standard in both
instances your solution as a commander
is a physical fitness program that will
provide
for progressive and continuous physical
conditioning of your men
it can and should be integrated into
a phase of pro of phases of
training in your program as an asset to
your unit commander is the highly
developed sports program and he talks
about
how important that is how important it
is to
to have these kind of programs where
you're running
he talks about care of equipment
got to take care of your gear he uses
this little quote in here um
remember the rhyme rhyme the rhyme
about for want of a nail and i've never
heard have you ever heard that before
so i had to look it up for one of a nail
the shoe was lost for one of the shoe
the horse was lost for one of the horse
the rider was lost for one of a rider
the battle was lost for one of the
battle the kingdom was lost
all for the wand of a horse nail there's
that little thing
just that little just that little thing
talks about he goes into like this is
where i started kind of breezing through
some stuff because he's talking about
he's getting in the weeds a little bit
about how do you get people to take care
of their vehicles he's
he goes through some execution charts
proficiency of weapons
testing the abilities of soldiers he
runs into this a little bit performance
testing and talks about
how you've got to continually test
people
so that you know that they can do their
job
schooling he talks about schooling of
the individuals and again this is
he starts getting into some of the weeds
and then he gets into professionalism
and professionalism to me is um
you know a word you know talk about
your first experience in the military
and how that leaves a mark
well in 1991
when i checked into seal team one there
was an
underlying theme
of professionalism it was hey
professionalism seal team one the the
nickname for seal team one was stalag
team one
because you know we had haircut
inspections every two weeks
or yeah and then uniform inspections i
think the first monday of every month
seal team five they we can we can
confirm this with jason gardner but i
don't think they had uniform inspections
in the decade so you know everyone
looked at team one the stalog team won
and it was this is that the underlying
tone was professionalism
back to the book in today's army we can
afford to keep only the worthwhile
individual in our ranks every effort
must be made to strive for
professionalism in all things
retention of the desirable and dedicated
individual is the goal
constant supervision by officers and
non-commissioned officers
is necessary to raise standards of
performance a great deal
can be accomplished by each individual
by setting the example
and being a professional himself more
than
any other thing demonstrated competence
ability
and efficiency i.e professionalism will
encourage new officers and enlisted men
to make the army their profession
what is real professionalism for the
career army officer many do not
understand what is meant by
professionalism i submit that
professionalism to the young soldier
to the career non-commissioned officer
to the young reserve officer on limited
active duty and to the reserve officer
on extended active duty is different
from that applicable to the career
regular army officer with 20 years of
service
i will explain this as i see it if you
are enumerate if you enumerate
the various things that have to be done
in order to produce a combat ready army
to meet the demands of our country in
case of emergency
i believe you will find that these
necessary
operations pretty well cover cover the
field in creating an army so here's the
list of things that you have to do
in order to create an army raising an
army
organizing the army equipping the army
training the army
supplying the army leading and
commanding the army
administering the army moving the army
communicating within the army
employing the army a career
regular army officer who wants to
prepare himself to be a professional
should learn the general requirements
techniques and principles of
each one of these necessary operations
in addition
he should become a master of one
and have at least one other as a strong
minor
and i think that's probably a pretty
good place to stop right now we could go
all day with this but
what's interesting i find it interesting
about that is
if you've got 10 broad operational
fields
in the army and you can only be a master
in one of them
because we just don't have the ability
to be more than that you could be a
minor in another
then how can you be a professional right
because i was kind of expecting him to
say you need to learn all these things
he says you can only become a master
wanted you can only become a minor and
one more
so i'm thinking how do you become a
professional
and i think the answer is humility
to actually know that you're not a
master of everything to actually know
that you have shortfalls and you have
deficiencies
and then what you do is you surround
yourself with people that
are masters in those areas you build a
team
you build a team and that starts with
humility it starts with knowing your
weaknesses
so you can turn those weaknesses
into strengths by bringing the right
people
into your organization
there you go echo charles
yes speaking of turning weaknesses into
strengths
sure do you have anything that can kind
of help us maybe turn
weaknesses into strength technically
factually actually
do you know you're known for saying the
word factually i do now yeah
yeah some people will occasionally just
throw a just a factually like
comments yeah apparently my daughter
gives me
[ __ ] about that as well so i couldn't
you understand what i'm saying anyway so
yes okay we're on the path
right turning weaknesses in into
strengths
okay so the thing we don't want to worry
about is our joints so
speaking of comments maybe we should
just ask the question you were gone for
two podcasts
yes this whole sort of support section
you know it was like i don't know three
minutes seven minutes
something like that yeah way too short
maybe people could put in the comments
you know what you know
how they're feeling about that maybe
they missed it yes
well we'll just say technically
the support section factually as well
yeah
it the support section and all these
fine products and services are infused
into this section as a whole same scene
so the section isn't only about support
it's how to stay on the path straight up
that's what the sex
section is if you want to you know get
all namey
naming things as far as sections go
anyway
thing you don't want to worry about is
your joints when you're on this path
that we're all on you definitely don't
want to be worried about your doings no
sir so chocolate supplements
overall a bunch of supplements all
jockly supplements called jocko fuel
the joint supplements to keep your
joints in the game
don't have to worry about them not to
think about them
don't have to consider them
when you're doing individual specific
things
i like when you paint yourself into a
corner and then you gotta kind of work
your way out of there verbally yeah you
know it's funny because
individual specific things that's yeah
nonetheless joints we're not worried
about them when we're doing deep squats
we're not worried about joints you know
why because we're on this joint warfare
super krill oil you you go on that
consistently you don't worry about none
of that stuff you're worried about your
gains
so speaking of gains boom mulk
i know i'm skipping around don't worry
about it i got you
protein in the form of dessert that's
what you take after you're working out
so boom
breakdown build back up all good okay so
here's what we do want to talk about
discipline and discipline go wait can i
add something on the mulk
scenario sure because there is something
to talk about
it's a little something called smashing
pumpkin oh yeah it's a new flavor
have you tried it no it literally came
in when i was leaving right now it is
it is at the top of my list right have
you got it yet dave negative it is it
just is at the top of the list right now
it's just beat everything
now part of that is because it's new and
i'm sure there's some level of
hey just like the variety and it tastes
good
to have something different but i am i
already
you know pete and brian well you know
it's a seasonal thing i was like no
stop this is not a seasonal thing
there's no this is this is a new
this is in the game this is this is this
is part of jocko fuel
smashing pumpkin i don't even i didn't
even really understand what pumpkin
have you ever eaten pumpkin before like
when you were a little kid carbon
pumpkins you just ate some because you
weren't eating no
not the raw pumpkin i did though right i
was like let's see what this tastes like
it doesn't taste like anything right
basically it's slimy that makes sense
so i'm thinking what is what is pumpkin
flavored milk
gonna taste like slime you know i wasn't
really
sure because that's what pumpkin pumpkin
has no taste
kind of it's just sort of slimy yeah so
i wasn't 100 sure
but you know these guys are all fired up
and they send me the sample
and i mix it i was like good lord i
don't even so it's
it's a pumpkin spice yes flavor
okay there's a cinnamon
situation but what it i don't know look
does it taste like pumpkin spice maybe
i've never
really eaten anything that tasted like
pumpkin spice
let me tell you this it tastes freaking
good it tastes
real good it tastes shockingly
good yeah i understand you know what
pumpkin spice is right
i i don't know i kind of oh this is a
thing
yeah it's a thing it's a flavor like yes
my wife will get
pumpkin spice drink something right some
latte or something okay so
you know so yeah that's why it's funny
when you're like i've never eaten
anything with pumpkin so yeah because
that's not what pumpkin spice
tends pumpkin spice tends to be like
drinks and stuff you know they're trendy
drinks that's what it gets like
you know the wrap for or whatever it's a
fall
thing it's a seasonal thing it's kind of
softy softy kind of thing maybe that's
why pete was all like
seasonal oh yeah what else did you just
say besides seasonal
softy softy oh okay it's fall it's a
fall
thing because you complete my means
towards you know like that
oh yeah i dig it i mean you gotta have
balance you gotta bounce for sure
sometimes we wonder if pete
listens to these parts of the podcast
and i can tell
if he does or does not because he i'm
always
busting his chops here whether he
listens or not
he's kind of missing out and he can't
defend himself yeah so you either listen
or you can't defend yourself
you're called pete yeah but we know that
you're leaning towards
what'd you say comfy comfy softy softy
soft because i didn't tell you he hadn't
even tried pumpkin spice yet
he hadn't even tried smashing pumpkin
today oh that actually i told him
and i said bro this stuff is so good
this stuff is so good he goes i haven't
even tried it yet
i go because he's got a sweet tooth yeah
like that guy mainlines baklava
like it's going out of style and people
send that guy you know they send him
like cookies and donuts and stuff
just to just to torment him
so pumpkin spice anyways smashing
pumpkin
mulk wait not anyways we're still
getting to the bottom of the pumpkin
spice thing i thought okay oh we're not
getting to the bottom of it no no go
ahead no no we don't have to get to the
bottom
i want to know i thought it was a food
yeah exactly that's kind of my point
right so you know how you were saying
okay my wife you know my wife gets it
it's a trendy thing
right so pizza is seasonal but it is
halloween that's a pumpkin thing too
yes that that i do know okay pumpkin
spice think about pumpkin
pie you have pumpkin pie before yeah and
again to me
okay yes i've had it okay so like
consider like and this is the closest i
can get it get to it is like a
cinnamon added to the pumpkin pie what
kind of
flavor got it you see i'm saying yeah
and then boom malk all good
but so seasonal is it because of fall
season or is it because of halloween
season
you know jack-o-lanterns and whatnot
well pumpkins
yeah halloween just you think not the
father because pumpkin spices fall
that's a fall
thing you see insane all right but it's
not seasonal i quit
i'm asking you about the mulk is it
seasonal now or is it not seasonal can
look in january
or march or spring or whatever we won't
keep it in the moment
because it's too freaking good yeah
smashing pumpkin
i believe it actually when you mentioned
it i was like dang that's whoever came
up with that kind of idea for
milk like that's pretty that's good
that's all it is it's really good
i'm not sure it might have been my
daughter
who came up with the idea my daughter i
said we because my daughter
is into nutrition and stuff and she's
into mulk
and she's into mixing up recipes yeah
sure hell yeah
and i one day i was texting with her and
i said hey you know
what flavor do you want and one of the
things that she said she wanted was
pumpkin pumpkin spice which i didn't
even really know was a thing
it's a thing man yeah big time and hey
hey man you're down for it obviously you
like pumpkin spice apparently
so you know you're done i don't like
pumpkin spice i like smashing pumpkin
all right well there you go
you know there you go either way yes
okay so plenty other flavors too by the
way so all good
malt protein formula of a dessert and in
the form of
some pumpkin spice boom there you go
monk is good
um also okay i skipped around a little
bit we usually talk about the vitamin d
that's important too now the season's
changing you're not gonna be outside
that much
getting sun oh great i'm saying so boom
you want to be sure you got that kind of
stuff also
cold war it's free immune system vitamin
d is good for your immune system too but
boom
in combo same same deal you don't got to
worry about your sickness
let's face it i think everyone should be
upping their immune system at this point
in the world i think in time yes that is
my
there's plenty of reasons there's one
big reason
get that immune system kicking yes sir
it's true also chocolate white tea
get that in bags and in cans
what's up with the cans
well what's going on right now is we we
may have
initiated a little bit of a war
in the drink world in the in the canned
drink world
so where there might be a delay in
getting jack a white
tea back in the game we've been
we've been drawn into a there's been
there's been a
declaration of war against
jaco discipline gokans yes yes so we're
it's it's on i'm not going to talk too
much detail but
let me just say we are at war
and and look it's one thing when you're
kind of down there and you're scrapping
and you're you know but whatever
you're just having a good time but then
all of a sudden you realize you
you're at war yeah and so we had some
events
unfold that some some big
actors have taken action
to attempt to suppress
our people yeah
so we're gonna have to fight yeah oh
yeah yeah look forward to hearing more
about that one
plans and whatnot nonetheless you did
mention discipline go
so discipline jocko discipline and
discipline goal discipline is the powder
discipline go is the cans and pills and
capsules by the way
but we're talking about the cans rtd and
all ready to drink
right this was for yep ready to drink
deploy um
okay a health a healthy actual healthy
energy drink
actually healthy though not the kind
like
no no no actually healthy yeah actually
healthy
good no preservative no nothing okay
available
in wawa vitamin shop and online
boom speaking of war so check this out
part of this war is
driving and crushing the enemy
so we're not in all wawa's yet we want
to
and by the way wawa is just the
beginning but we got a crush
so check this out so right now we're
only in florida the florida wawa's
we have like a battle map especially now
that we're
at war we have a battle map if you're
check this out
if you want to support the cause go to
wawa in florida
and just clean out just get yourself
some discipline go
get yourself some discipline go and help
us win the war
appreciate it also vitamin shop you can
get it there if you don't have a wawa
near you
also com origenmaine.com
and let's face it also amazon yes
yep available yeah prime you mentioned
originbean.com other stuff on
orgymain.com
jiu-jitsu stuff yes we'll say everyday
stuff
to wear jeans specifically american
denim it's a big deal
american denim also boots on there real
good stuff um
yeah go in there get something man if
you want something american-made stuff
it's not like that's not a big deal yeah
by the way you may have been looking for
delta 68 jeans
they were unavailable for a while
they're back
we're we're catching up right now and
they're freaking awesome
and i have a confession to make
you know how i'm always like you know i
mean i literally have written books
about putting your people out of you and
taking care of the people and all that
you already know they come fast so
there we kind of re-engineered the delta
genes a little bit
we re-engineered the fabric a little bit
we re-engineered the cut
and so pete sent me like
the we we went back and forth like three
iterations finally sent the iteration
like recently yeah he sent me like okay
this should be it
i put him on i sent him a text i'm like
execute
send me two pairs immediately put me
above everyone else's weight
i got a package so i have i've all my
other genes are in the garbage
because now it's just delta delta 68 the
best things
ever um yeah totally good to go
so if you want those you can get those
what's funny is like now you're not too
mad at pete for his design
and fashion it's functional design
functional fashion
can we say functional fashion yeah
sounds good
good job pete man keep up keep being you
pee
great guy anyway also we have a jacquard
has a store it's called jocko's store
got some i swear if you want to
represent you want discipline equals
freedom shirts
hats hoodies some board shorts on there
boom all that stuff i'm wearing them
right now by the way oh yeah
but heavy rotation oh yeah camouflage
and black
well some other ones on there too some
good stuff you say we'll have other ones
on there you will have other ones on
there
oh dang oh yeah look at you sure
decentralized commands oh man
oh yeah we're doing the best uh we can
over there anyway yeah some good stuff
on there christmas is coming up
maybe not this month but soon see i'm
saying i'm just saying
there's there are good gift items on
there you know yes so
dracostore.com if you want something get
something
don't forget to subscribe to the podcast
because echo charles thinks you should
don't forget that we have some other
podcasts one's called jocko unraveling
which echo should be putting out some
episodes
it has its own thread it has its own
thread now feeds his own feed
so if you want to get the unraveling
podcast it's on its own feed
that one you can subscribe to to make
sure you're getting them when they come
out
there's we have some in the bank let's
get them out okay
i'm not talking to everyone else echo
charles i'm just talking to you right
now
this isn't like this isn't a kind of a
universal statement to the people
this is the most statement for one
person yes sir we have episodes
in the bank we don't want them in the
bank we want to spend them we want to
get them out to the people
i understand fully is that
what's the man hours that it takes to
get that down
uh roughly what point two
okay an hour so maybe it's something we
could make happen that's
very possible yes uh here's the thing
about that though okay so the the
unraveling
podcast used to be called the thread it
used to be so if you're subscribed to
the thread if you were
and then it's in your like libra i don't
know the different sections yeah
and then i'm talking about um like
itunes
podcast or whatever i'm not sure if it
works for stitcher i'm not sure
it might very well but it'll be in your
library still
but you'll when you click on there it
won't indicate that you're subscribed so
you just got to click it again
okay so you don't have to go search for
it is what i'm saying if you were
already
subscribed but you know if you're not
then yeah go there so the unraveling
the jocko unraveling podcast subscribe
to it it's me and
daryl cooper grounded podcast
warrior kid podcast we have a youtube
channel if you want to see what good
deal dave burke looks like
uh or if you want to see what echo
charles looks like if you want to see
what i look like or you want to see some
enhanced videos that echo puts his
effort into allegedly
and a lot of the videos you got to
remember some people they go oh
you know echo good job and they always
forget
that echo might be the guy that pressed
the record but i'm the assistant
director
to these videos there's no the i'm the
the kind of the the glue that brings it
together
assistant director that's me so keep
that in mind
if you want to see videos that have me
as the assistant director
subscribe to our youtube channel hey we
got an album called psychological
warfare
a bunch of me talking about how to
overcome whatever problem you're dealing
with flip side canvas
dakota meyer making awesome things to
hang on your wall bunch of books about
face
by hackworth i wrote the forward to the
newest edition leadership strategy and
tactics field manual
discipline equals freedom field manual
brand new version is out right now
way the warrior kid 4 field manual
is out right now i just brought the
first copies in one for dave and his
kids one for echo and his kids
way the warrior kid one two and three
are out mikey and the dragons
just got elected selected on amazon.com
as
a teacher's pick teacher's pick
kind of a big deal yeah oh yeah kind of
a big deal very cool so thanks all the
teachers out there that selected mikey
and the dragons to be a teacher's
pick on amazon.com extreme ownership and
the dichotomy leadership
where it started also we have echelon
front
it's our leadership consultancy where we
solve problems through leadership
go to echelonfront.com for details
we also have ef online which is online
interactive training for leadership is a
skill for leadership
remember not sitting there earlier
saying hey why would you go into a room
if you haven't trained why would you
think you could
know how to have a conversation if you
had good yeah it takes training
we know that so we made online training
ef online if you want to ask
dave a question if you want to ask dave
if you want to ask dave about
dropping the first j damn in history
and what courage it took to do that
then you can go to efonline.com and
monday wednesday friday we are live we
are there
we're answering questions if you want to
know how awesome it was when i was doing
shipboardings in the gulf
overcoming fear to board these smugglers
vessels
no but seriously if you want to ask us
questions you want to talk about
leadership go to
ef online.com we also have the muster
there's only gonna be one muster this
year
it's in dallas texas it's december third
and fourth check out
extremeownership.com
we've got we've got social distancing
covid protocol in place we're not going
to do jiu jitsu
we usually do judiciary last night but
what we're going to do instead of jiu
jitsu
we're going to do a jiu jitsu philosophy
course of instruction q a
myself and another black belt will be
there
maybe two other black belts one of them
will be echo charles
i'll probably get another one yeah i'm
going to talk about jiu jitsu how those
how the gg2 principles
apply to life and i've been doing some
writing about jiu jitsu
which should be coming out shortly so i
might read
a little precursor of that
and then ef overwatch if you need
executive leadership inside your company
go to efoverwatch.com we have military
veterans that understand these
principles that are ready to go to work
if you're a company
that needs veterans go to eforewatch.com
if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families around the world then
check out
mark lee's mom she's got a charity
organization
mama lee it's called america's mighty
warriors and if you want to donate or
you want to get involved then go to
america's mighty mightywarriors.org
and if you find yourself
thirsting for more pain
and you want more of my droning drudgery
or you want more of
echoes farcical folklore
or maybe you just want some more of
dave's overzealous
zingers then you can find us on the
interwebs
on twitter instagram which echo will
only refer to as
the gram and on facebook dave is at
david r burke
echoes adequate charles and i am at
jocko willing and thanks to
general bruce clark and colonel david
hackworth for leading
our nation's best in combat and for
passing on those lessons to us
and thanks to all the people in uniform
out there right now putting those
lessons to use
keeping democracy and freedom safe in
the world
and to police and law enforcement to
firefighters paramedics and emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service and other first
responders
thank you for keeping us safe here at
home
and everyone else out there remember
what you have heard
from general clark
remember what he said that it all starts
with discipline
the army is built on discipline
but so so are us so are we
as individuals general clark said that
the one thing that will keep a trainee
on the right track is discipline that's
the one thing the supreme
thing
so maybe we should be more disciplined
and maybe we
should stay on the right track maybe we
should stay
on the path every single day
by getting after it and until next time
this is dave and echo and jocko
out